but we're going to begin with this
there's a new fight over abortion access
that could become the biggest battle on
this issue since Roe v Wade was
overturned protests erupted in multiple
cities after a federal judge in Texas
suspended the FDA approval of a
well-known commonly used abortion pill
now that decision affects the entire
country think about that for just a
second but then another federal judge
this one in Washington state ruled that
the pills cannot be restricted in more
than a dozen states so Nancy Cordes is
following all of this at the White House
Nancy there are a lot of moving parts to
this story good morning to you good
morning to you yes these are two of the
most consequential legal decisions since
Roe v Wade was struck down last year and
the legal Whiplash leaves millions of
women caught in the middle this is
likely to be settled right back at the
Supreme Court the president is vowing to
fight the Texas ruling and the
Department of Justice is Seeking a stay
hands off the abortions Hill protests
broke out this weekend over the abortion
pill ruling that has the potential to
affect not just women in Texas but women
across the country this is going to
create utter chaos utter disruption of
women's lives a conservative federal
judge in Texas ruled Friday that the FDA
improperly approved the abortion pill
mifa priston 23 years ago ignoring
legitimate safety concerns about the
drug the order yesterday was all about
writing a wrong mifiperstone is one of
two approved pills that are used
together to carry out more than half of
legal abortions in this country the FDA
insists the drug is safe and that
serious complications are rare this
ruling is an extreme abuse of power some
lawmakers urged the Biden Administration
to resist enforcing the ruling we know
that the executive branch has an
enforcement discretion especially
visually in light of a contradicting
ruling coming out of Washington shortly
after the Texas ruling a Washington
state judge blocked any changes to
mifiperstone's availability in 17 States
and the District of Columbia as
Administration officials warned that the
legal battle in Texas could have
far-reaching implications when you turn
upside down the entire FDA approval
process you're not talking about just
Memphis pristo you're talking about
every kind of drug cases like this one
ensure that abortion will remain a top
issue in next year's elections
it helped to propel liberal judge Janet
proteasewitz to an 11-point win in a
high-profile state supreme court race in
Wisconsin just last week sparking some
debate among Republicans about exactly
how far to go we can win this issue at
The Ballot Box if we show up with
reasonable positions if we have our head
in the sand we're going to lose
for now many prescribers say they're
going to continue to dispense
methopristone and patients and states
where abortion is restricted can
continue to order the medication from
abroad even if the FDA is forced to
withdraw approval of miffapristone it is
likely the drug would still be available
for months or even years as the agency
Works to reduce the regulation so very
confusing situation right now Tony
yeah and the fight will continue Nancy
thank you very much